réunion au sommet entre les deux
allemagnes dans 15 bureaux en allemagne
de l'est ce véritable chasse aux
sorcières par ville des profiteurs de
l'ancien régime la politique
d'immigration et d'intégration examiné
demain enfoncer des ministres à prochain
jeu télévisé à relents racistes entre
jean marie le pen et lionel stoléru le
record du monde de vitesse sur rail est
un nouveau français fut de 480 km heure
à l'activité gvt et atlantico le russe
et puis collision à lille entre un
airbus et un petit avion privé le pire
évité vue cesse une enquête est ouverte
voilà monsieur bonsoir dans un pays
démocratique comme le nôtre est dans un
débat entre hommes politiques
existe-t-il des limites à la liberté
d'expression
existe-t-il des mots des formules à
bannir
la réponse est oui sauf à utiliser à
détourner le débat démocratique et en
l'occurrence les médias pour attiser le
racisme et l'antisémitisme
c'est ce qui s'est passé tout à l'heure
sur la cinq où lionel stoléru le
secrétaire d'état chargé du plan
affronter jean marie le pen au coeur du
débat
en principe les problèmes de
l'immigration en fait écouter dirigea
que vous ayez la double nationalité
laquelle je ne sais pas je vous pose la
question je vais vous une double
nationalement je suis français tout ça
vous n'avez pas de double nationalité je
n'ai pas à parfaire le jeu j'aime mieux
ça parce que j'aurai il fallait jouer tu
dois vous le dire un peu gêné si j'avais
su que vous aviez une autre nationalité
galles que la nationalité française vous
pose la question on me dit que non un
angle c'est quand il n'y a pas là de
débats je voudrais seulement vous dire
c'est sûr et aïn sur l'analyse non
cotées pas ce genre d'argument pitoyable
monsieur soleil ce qui pendait d'orgueil
personnel je vous pose la question vous
êtes un ministre français
on a droit de savoir qui vous êtes
écoutez je pense que c'est normal je
vais vous dire une chose l'immigration
que l'exclusion à l'intérieur je crois
qu'il faut que les choses soient claires
parce que vous avez un langage un peu
côté monsieur les rues vous êtes juif ou
non c'est pas une nationalité et enfin
sauf et je pense que monsieur le pen
faisait peut-être l'usure la possibilité
que vous avez une double nationalité
israélienne et française
oui c'est la question que je lui posais
mes mais puisqu'on m'a dit ça mais j en
sais rien moi je ne crois pas ce qu'on
dit systématiquement est je crois la
loyauté monsieur stoléru gentil de votre
part sur le port à la vraiment très
gentils très bien jusqu'à présent juif
est une religion mais je moi je vous ai
pas parlé des amis de venir je ne vous
ai pas parlé juste je sais que vous êtes
président de la chambre de commerce
franco israélienne
mais comme on m'avait dit que vous étiez
en même temps laissez moi parler comme
on m'avait dit que vous étiez en même
temps de nationalité israélienne
je vous posais la question mais puisque
vous dites que vous ne l'êtes pas
j'accepte cette affirmation et jean
marie le pen à un autre moment du débat
de qualifiés de rafles une opération
décrite par monsieur sto les rues parmi
les immigrés clandestins
le tout disons le journal et le scène au
moment où pèsent de plus en plus dans
l'opinion dans la vie politique aussi
les problèmes complexes de l'immigration
et de l'intégration
le tout ils ont le exhalent des relents
un peu nauséabondes doux et christine
après le le détail de l'histoire un tout
petit détail puisqu'il s'agissait des
camps de concentration après durafour
crématoire un mauvais jeu de mots mais ô
combien révélateur que pouvait bien a
vanté jean marie le pen pour contrer
lyonnaise les rues encore un mot rien
qu'un petit mot quand le secrétaire
d'état au plomb a évoqué les opérations
coup de poing dans le quartier du
sentier à paris pour lutter contre le
travail au noir
le président du front national n'a rien
trouvé de mieux à dire que vous pourriez
organiser une rafle c'est le cas de le
dire
rafle le mot est lâché on pense au vel
d'hiv on se souvient des trains de
drancy mais jean marie le pen lui c'est
que dans le contexte actuel
le procédé est payant et qu'il peut
persévérer car même en abaissant le
sous-entendu au rang de tactique
politique il est sûr de son bon droit la
justice le débat jamais de ski et
sournois l'autre point noir de ce duel
sur l'a5 celle amalgames on vient de
vous
arles amalgame entre nationalités et
religions aidé par la maladresse du
meneur de jeu le leader du front
national en arrive à confondre
publiquement juifs et israéliens mais
qui pourrait bien accuser l'open
d'antisémitisme devant les tribunaux
réponse personne
l'insinuation et rennes et les
manipulateurs de mots sont rois faute de
mieux la maîtrise de l'immigration et la
politique d'intégration feront l'objet
demain matin en conseil des ministres
d'une communication michel rocard le
comité interministériel à l'intégration
sera officiellement créé de la sphère du
foulard à dreux le gouvernement comme
les milieux politiques s'efforcent bien
sûr de réajuster tantôt leurs actions
quant aux leurs positions ainsi alain
juppé le secrétaire général du rpr
estime je le cite que l'opposition a
bien du travail à faire pour être sur la
même ligne de pensée et d'action sur ces
problèmes qui conditionne at il ajouté
son avenir politique et son avenir
électoral à sa demande l'opposition
organisera début mars une convention sur
les thèmes de l'identité nationale de
l'immigration et de l'intégration des
thèmes qui depuis une trentaine d'années
avec des effets contradictoires pèse sur
la vie politique et la vie collective en
france
agnès poirier jean-michel mercure
aujourd'hui j'en ai besoin de trois ans
alors moi de manga doit rendre au toit
du 10e au quart numéro 487 no comment
t'appelles le vauréen
l'air numéro khalfallah forêt toujours
dit rainer rau l'économie française est
en pleine expansion
le pays a besoin de bras dans les années
l'office nationale d'immigration recrute
tous fui la situation économique de leur
pays portugal algérie maroc italie
turquie en france rien n'est fait pour
les accueillir
pénurie de logements il s'installe dans
des cités de transit des bidonvilles ils
sont maçons peintres manoeuvre ouvriers
spécialisés une main d'oeuvre bon marché
de cils que l'on embauche ou licencient
selon les besoins au jour le jour
francis bride en sait quelque chose au
début des années 70 son entreprise de
construction en bâtiment employés 80 %
d'immigrés et l'on nous qualité
fondamentale pour moi employeurs qui a
toute ma sympathie c'est que s'ils
viennent chez nous c'est pour travailler
par contre parfois d'autres langues sont
pas tellement qualifier
et puis viennent avec une idée en tête
c'est d'amasser un pécule et nous
quitter en viseront un pécule suffisant
mais en fait très peu repartiront en 74
pour la première fois valéry giscard
d'estaing homme un secrétaire d'état aux
immigrés andré postel vinay il fait
voter par l'assemblée la fermeture des
frontières mais très vite démissionne
devant l'absence d'une réelle politique
sociale en faveur des immigrés
lorsqu'une entreprise par exemple estimé
d'avoir besoin de mille turcs
eh bien elle demandait l'introduction en
france 2010 turc et elle obtenait
généralement satisfaction et les mines
turques lui a été livré à l'entrée de
lusine et moyennant une redevance à
payer râle office de migration
l'immigration qui s'élevait à 250 francs
par turk
mais aucune mesure d'accueil donc une
politique globale en mars 77 lionel
stoléru arrive au gouvernement sa
solution l'aide au retour
une politique pour accompagner la
diminution de la main d'oeuvre étrangère
en france parce que tous nous montre
autour de nous le bon sens en na'vi
quotidienne que par rapport au quinze
années de croissance rapide du passé
nous changeons d'époque et il y aura
probablement dans les quinze années qui
viennent une diminution régulière de la
main d'oeuvre étrangère en france
on propose aux travailleurs immigrés
10000 front pour partir on interdit aux
femmes et aux enfants d'immigrés de
travail et 1980 la loi bonnet permet de
les expulser s'il troublent l'ordre
public ou s'ils sont en situation
irrégulière qui en 1981 un changement de
cap
cent trente mille travailleurs
clandestins voient leur situation
régularisée l'aide au retour est
supprimé et le regroupement familial à
nouveau favoriser 183 à l'heure où les
jeunes beurs manifestent contre le
racisme le front national commence à
marquer les points
le gouvernement favorise l'intégration
des immigrés de longue date
il crée la carte de résident de 10 ans
mais combat l'immigration clandestine
économique est porteuse de risques
graves
il ne faut pas se dissipe les lois
pasqua conditions draconiennes pour
l'entrée le séjour des immigrés un mois
plus tard on n'en renvoient les
clandestins par charters entiers dans
leur pays en juillet 89 la loi joxe
aboli la world pasqua dans sa plus
grande partie les frontières est fermée
à toute immigration nouvelle pour
l'actuel ministre de l'intérieur la
priorité est désormais à l'intégration
la sphère des foulards a montré
l'urgence d'une véritable politique dans
un pays qui compte plus 4 millions de
travailleurs immigrés six semaines il
aura fallu six semaines après
l'effondrement du mur de berlin et du
rideau de fer pour en venir à la
rencontre au sommet entre les deux
allemagnes elle aura lieu le 19 décembre
prochain en allemagne de l'est n'ont pas
à berlin mais à dresde
le chancelier kohl et rencontrera
officiellement le premier ministre reste
allemand hans modrow donc avant le
président mitterrand qui sera lui à vers
la hesse le vin par ailleurs pour la
première fois depuis la fin de la guerre
la libre circulation sur le territoire
des deux allemagne sera rétabli puisqu'à
partir du 1er janvier prochain les
allemands de l'ouest pourront se rendre
librement à l'est quel chemin dans les
faits et dans les esprits parcouru en
quelques semaines
philippe lefait et quelle histoire
le 9 novembre deux jours après la chute
du gouvernement et la démission du
bureau politique
c'est le mur de berlin une bastille
communiste qui vole en éclats ce symbole
froid de la guerre avec lui les
frontières sont ouvertes les allemands
de l'est se ruent pour une visite chez
les cousins riches ils sont 3 millions à
succomber à la tentation en 48 heures
plus politique déjà une journée passe et
les maires des deux berlin échangent une
poignée de main là où quelques mois plus
tôt des gardes-frontières empêcher la
liberté à coups de fusil sur le mur la
fête continue la destruction aussi alors
que les polémique éclate sur la
réunification de l'allemagne l'europe
washington moscou s'inquiète
réunification le mot est dans les têtes
personnes en a encore parlé publiquement
qu'à cela ne tienne deux semaines
suffisent que déjà le non-dit devient
proposition ferme et kohl le chancelier
ouest allemand ce 29 novembre explose un
plan en dix points qui vise à terme à
restaurer l'unité allemande presque
l'annnonce de l'an 1 de la réunification
et d'un nouvel équilibre européen en
devenir à l'ouest on se veut circonspect
mais confiant je ne me ferai pas des
aspirations exprimées par des
personnalités allemandes s'est toujours
dit qu'elle était légitime et le monde
tourne à 100 à l'heure l'allemagne aussi
c'est notamment pour en discuter qu'il y
a deux jours les maîtres de l'otan et du
pacte de varsovie
les alliances militaires qui fige
l'après-guerre se rencontrent le message
comme un éclair ou jeudi les frontières
sont les frontières
gorbatchev répond il y a deux allemagnes
mais déjà et encore hier soir dans les
rues de leipzig allemagne de l'est ont
scandé référendum réunification quelle
histoire
l'histoire est aujourd'hui les maires
des deux berlin ont eu leur premier
entretien officiel pour discuter de la
coopération entre leurs communes en
allemagne de l'est dans plusieurs villes
du pays
la majorité de la population se livrent
depuis quelques jours à une véritable
chasse aux sorcières et veut punir la
corruption de l'ancien système
le procureur général et son adjoint ont
démissionné aujourd'hui et surtout
on apprend que l'ancien numéro 1 erich
honecker est assigné à résidence
virtuellement prisonniers philippe
rouchon au necker derrière les barreaux
les manifestants de litige ne croyait
pas si bien dire
il est placé en résidence surveillée
avant de liszt où logeaient les cadres
du parti
egon krenz est montré du doigt comme un
chef de mafia
le parti communiste doit s'en aller
scande la foule le prince trésorier
stalinien goldau sz qui a aussi une
résidence à haïti jodlowski c'est lui
dirigeants communistes dans la tête est
mise à prix par la foule
il est en fuite à l'ouest golder ce qui
a détourné des centaines de millions de
marks et organiser un vaste trafic
d'armes
le peuple doit décider que le pouvoir du
parti communiste disparaissent avenue
karl marx à berlin les allemands de
l'est découvre la richesse clinquante et
dorée d'un parti dont cinq dirigeants
sont déjà sous les verrous et dont 30 ou
fonctionnaires font l'objet d'une
enquête judiciaire
les limousines des membres du comité
central où les voitures de la police
politique ne représente que la face
cachée d'un immense trafic difficilement
calculable mais à cause duquel la
population se serrer la ceinture
egon krenz lui même le numéro un est
allemand est menacée
cette épuration qui touche surtout les
cadres du parti ne fait que commencer
dans toutes les grandes villes de la rda
on assiste ce soir à des perquisitions à
des mises sous scellés d'appartements ce
qui achève de discréditer le parti
communiste est-allemand
à dix jours de son congrès et ce soir un
mandat d'arrêt a été lancé contre
wolfgan vos gueules ce célèbre avocat
est-allemand spécialiste des échanges de
personnes entre les deux allemagnes il
est accusé depuis de chantage en
tchécoslovaquie les négociations ont
repris cet après midi entre le premier
ministre et les dirigeants du forum
civique
ce qui n'a pas empêché de nouvelles
manifestations hostiles au régime
l'un des deux gouvernements fédéraux le
tchèque par opposition aux slovaques a
été remaniée aujourd'hui pour la
première fois les communistes y perdent
la majorité même s'il garde les postes
de premier ministre et de ministre de
l'intérieur
depuis hier la frontière avec l'autriche
est en certains endroits complètement
ouverte à la circulation mais le
démantèlement du rideau de fer sera
progressif dans les jours qui viennent
le reportage dans un petit village
frontalier d'aubry adler et alain saint
remy réelle sortie les brumes qu'il
paraît ne jamais devoir finir le rideau
de fer commence ici en slovaquie aux
portes de bratislava où s'entremêlent
frontière autrichienne hongroise et
tchécoslovaques construit dès 1948 le
long ruban de barbelés n'a cessé de
s'étoffer depuis isolant de l'autre
monde le pays tout entier
le cataclysme qui ébranle en ce moment
le régime de prague ne semble pas avoir
bouleversé l'ordre ancien qui règne isme
pourtant scènes inimaginables il ya dix
jours encore la conversation entre
passants et sentinelles car depuis la
promesse du gouvernement
entrouvrir dans deux semaines le rideau
chacun guette espère pour tout de suite
cet instant de revente
en 40 ans d'histoire à des vignettes
sont les plus ardents encore collés aux
barbelés le village déclarés zones
sensibles est restée isolée jusqu'en 62
seuls quelques tchécoslovaque pour vente
y pénétrer voit-on pas dire que vous
êtes virés comme des chiens enfermés
dans une cage
maintenant beaucoup de gens vont enfin
pouvoir aller à l'étranger mais là c'est
à ce moment là on pourra comparer
l'autre côté avec le nom évidemment on
espère beaucoup
bien sûr on s'est habitué aux rideaux de
fer mais nous les vieux c'est surtout
pour les jeunes qu on est heureux
première victoire pour les habitants la
réouverture de la promenade qui suit le
rideau de fer en contrebas de delvin à
peine devenue la nouvelle ce sont des
familles entières qui viennent reprendre
possession de ce petit bout de
territoire symbole c'est possible le
village commence à y croire
quelque chose a bien changé dans le pays
est déjà chacun veut rapporter un
souvenir on arrache les panneaux militer
on ose même tenté de déplacer les
barbelés mais la liberté ne se
retrouvent facilite une patron de
l'armée intervient aussi par les
officiers sont nerveux furieux surtout
de nous prouver là se contenteront
pourtant de nous menacer d'expulsion
on posera sans doute encore attendre
pour que ces foudres se muant de
barbelés mais c'est leur droit à la
dignité que se débine ceux de tous les
villages meurtris par le rideau de fer
viennent aujourd'hui de retrouver
l'histoire s'accélère encore il ya une
demi-heure à la télévision
tchécoslovaque le secrétaire général du
parti vient d'annoncer la réhabilitation
de tous les communistes exclu après la
répression du printemps de prague il y à
21 ans ils étaient quelque cinq cent
mille victimes ainsi de la normalisation
menée à l'époque par l'actuel chef de
l'état du staff usac dont la démission
est demandée avec insistance par les
opposants le président mitterrand se
rendra demain à kiev en union soviétique
pour une rencontre de travail avec
mikhaïl gorbatchev à l'ordre du jour
bien sûr les transformations de l'europe
et vendredi le conseil européen se
réunira à strasbourg le président
mitterrand a poursuivi aujourd'hui ses
consultations avec les principaux
dirigeants politiques qu'il a reçu
successivement messieurs fabius chirac
puis le président du sénat monsieur
poher ensuite monsieur marchait et puis
l'udf pierre méhaignerie et enfin
françois léotard un vrai carrousel
aujourd'hui à l'hélice est une bonne
nouvelle plutôt inattendu le commerce
extérieur s'est redressée mois derniers
l'accusent même un excédent de 2,2
milliards de francs alors que le mois
précédent en où il enregistrait un très
lourd déficit plus de 9 milliards de
francs
pas de cocorico pourtant au ministère du
commerce extérieur où l'on prend en
compte des ventes ponctuelles comme
celle d'airbus ou du matériel militaire
et on attend la suite même s'il faut le
noter les échanges avec les partenaires
industrialisés se sont nettement
améliorées la fermeture du site de
renault guyancourt
à l'issue du comité central d'entreprise
de la régie tout à l'heure on apprend
que les négociations sur le plan social
de reclassement des salariés
commenceront dès vendredi
véronique auger en connaît déjà les
grandes lignes dans deux ans ces
ateliers seront vides objectifs de la
direction
le départ des 4000 salariés ne doit pas
provoquer de vagues dans les autres
du groupe on va donc essayer de
contenter tout le monde les plus âgés
auront droit à des pré retraites
les autres se verront proposer des
postes ailleurs dans l'un des
établissements de la régie à flins en
particulier où l'on envisage de faire
tourner les chaînes 20 heures sur
vingt-quatre dernières propositions
elle concerne les salariés étrangers ils
sont 60% à billancourt ceux qui
accepteraient de rentrer dans leur pays
recevrait d'abord un capital exemple un
ouvrier de 50 ans avec 20 ans
d'ancienneté recevrait près de 80 du
franc ont leur verserait en plus une
rente mensuelle jusqu'à l'âge de la
retraite
exemple un ouvrier de 50 ans avec 20 ans
d'ancienneté percevrait 1600 francs par
mois ci si certains s'obstinent à ne pas
vouloir saisir les chances qui leur
seront propose les offres d'emploi qui
leur seront proposés et qui seront des
offres d'emploi convenable il est clair
qu'à ce moment là ils sont licenciés
mais ce n'est qu'au terme de procédure
de reclassement de conseils des
discussions avec les individus que cette
éventualité se présenterait donc en
dernier recours en dernier recours le
plan social sera négocié avec les
syndicats mais la direction a déjà
prévenu il sera appliqué même sans leur
accord le capi ne sera pas soumis au
conseil constitutionnel tout comme le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale le garde
des sceaux renonce à saisir
l'instance suprême malgré la demande du
rpr bernard pons qui accusait vous le
savez bernard tapie d'utiliser sa
qualité de député pour mieux vendre en
bourse la société réaction tout à
l'heure de bernard pons le garde des
sceaux n'a pas rendu une décision il a
rendu un service face de citations aux
philippines mal avec hinault a bien du
mal à venir à bout de la rébellion
militaire les mutins tiennent toujours
le centre commercial et financier de mme
annie martin laroche joubert
une armée qui règle ses comptes
mais pas dans n'importe quel quartier à
makati le centre financier et
touristique de manille
l'objectif des soldats rebelles et en
partie atteint déstabiliser la
présidente cory aquino sur un plan
international
au milieu des combats de rue touristes
et hommes d'affaires étrangers plus de
cassan restent bloqués dans leurs hôtels
otages virtuel de ces affrontements les
convois d'évacuation ont dû faire demi
tour
trop dangereux une situation très
délicate pour correa qui nous difficile
d'ordonner un assaut massif en pleine
ville difficile aussi de prévoir
l'attitude de l'armée dont une partie
des revendications rejoint celle des
rebelles entre leurs exigences la
démission de cory aquino est une riposte
musclée du gouvernement les négociations
semblent flotter dans une certaine
improvisation
une certitude le peuple philippin
demeure passif devant ce putsch
dur constat pour cory aquino dure
réalité pour ceux qui comptent les morts
74 et les blessés plus de 500 depuis le
début de ces affrontements la trêve
durait depuis dix semaines c'était trop
beau accrochage ce matin sur la ligne de
démarcation à beyrouth
réponse innée
échange de tirs entre les troupes du
général aoun et les milices pro syrienne
à beyrouth le président élias hraoui
annonce qu'il demandera le retrait des
syriens mais pas avant le retour au
calme dans l'enclavé chrétienne combat
également à l'est du pays entre milices
chiites amal et hezbollah
enfin un raid israélien ces sept blessés
près de saïda soeur antoni mayer n'a pas
battu margaret thatcher au poste de
leader du parti conservateur britannique
mais que le premier ministre ne fait pas
l'unanimité du parti 60 députés sur 314
votes contre elle ce qui constitue un
rosaire
tous les plus beaux ratés de la
production soviétique rassemblés dans
une exposition à moscou exposition
organisée par une association de
consommateurs et le journal néo vélia on
y trouve notamment cette bouteille d'eau
minérale ménages d'une souris
réouverture demain des chantiers de
l'atlantique il y a quatre semaines la
direction avait fermé les chantiers pour
mettre fin à deux mois de débrayages
tournants
les syndicats doivent maintenant donner
une réponse à la direction
la cgc s'est déjà déclarée satisfaite
à la bourse de paris au symbolique de la
liste de référence cac 40 +0 01 % que
dollar s'échange à seafrance 09 60 au
cours officiel 480 2,4 kilomètres à
l'heure
c'est le nouveau record du monde de
vitesse sur rail réalisé aujourd'hui par
la sncf grâce au tgv atlantique
une prouesse technique extraordinaire
selon le ministre michel delbarre
philippe du mess pulvérisé le record du
monde de vitesse sur rail et vous de
482,4 kilomètres à l'heure cela
représente 134 mètres à chaque seconde
l'ancien record était détenu par les
allemands avec on a envie de dire
seulement 407 km à l'oeuvre pour
réaliser cet exploit la sncf a utilisé
une rame un peu modifié
composé de quatre voitures et de deux
motrices d'un poids de moins de 300
tonnes alors que les rames classiques
font presque 500 tonnes il faut
remarquer que ce record à plus de 480
kilomètres à l'heure a été atteint sans
le moindre incident ce qui signifie que
la sncf aurait pu pousser sa machine
pour aller plus vite encore
quoi qu'il en soit cet exploit réalisé
sur la nouvelle ligne paris-tours qui
entrera en service en septembre 90
points
- que les nouveaux tgv pourront
transporter en toute sécurité des
voyageurs à 300 voire 350 kilomètres à
l'heure sur les lignes régulières
à l'aéroport de lille-lesquin ce matin
la catastrophe a vraiment été évité de
justesse un airbus d'air inter a percuté
un petit avion de tourisme miracle aucun
blessé patrick esther 11h15 ce matin
l'airbus a320 d'air inter en provenance
de paris orly est en approche finale
pour atterrir à lille le pilote vient
d'obtenir l'autorisation de la tour de
contrôle ce qu'il ne sait pas c'est
qu'au sol un petit avion privé s'engage
au même instant sur la piste pour
décoller le brouillard couvre l'aéroport
et l'airbus se pose en mode automatique
il percute l'appareil et le fait
littéralement éclater le train
d'atterrissage avant se casse le nez de
l'airbus mord la poussière les 142
passagers et membres d'équipage sont
évacués d'urgence par les toboggans
gonflables un miracle il n'y aura pas un
seul blessé c'est un miracle aussi pour
le pilote de cet avion hollandais qui se
trouvait au milieu de la piste puisque
lui-même avec à un avion complètement
scalper si vous voulez eh bien il n'a
pas non plus n'est gratuit à la
responsabilité de l'accident incombait
au pilote du petit avion qui aurait pris
la piste sans en avoir l'autorisation
une faute qu'il a déjà payé d'une belle
frayeur dernier grand prix littéraire de
la saison l'interallié a été décerné
aujourd'hui alain gerber pour le verger
du diable publié chez grasset alain
gerber roman c'est déjà prolixe est
aussi journaliste spécialisé dans le
jazz le prix chateaubriand qui
récompense un ouvrage contribuant au
rayonnement culturel de la france a été
décerné à henri coulonges pour la lettre
kirilenko publié chez stock
les liaisons dangereuses de choderlos de
laclos sont on le sait mais répétons le
un chef-d'oeuvre un chef-d'oeuvre qui
hante aussi les cinéastes voici que
milos forman signe à son tour une
nouvelle adaptation brillante plus
original que les précédentes
le titre du film qui sort demain dans
les salles valmont nom du séducteur bien
sûr nicole cornu langlois
une trés somptueuse et fidèle
reconstitution historique du xviiie
siècle
l'affrontement entre l'innocence et la
décadence l'idéalisme et le cynisme des
personnages ambigus et passionné qui
joue avec le mal madame de merteuil
charmeuse et pulpeuse un vicomte de
valmont élégant et arrogant
madame de tourvel lucide aimante et les
très jeunes d'ancenis et cécile de
volanges ce sont les atouts qui ont
séduit cet américain d'adoption tchèque
d'origine et de coeur qui doit cette
découverte littéraire à milan kundera
les français par mieux les liaisons
dangereuses
c'était génial cédric n'a pas vraiment
expliqué la littérature il a provoqué un
enthousiasme l'a fait il a parlé des
choses d'une façon qui nous a fait
courir à la maison et prendre le livre
de le vivre sans nous dire comment le
lire c'est que mon avis c'était
très mal an et comment avez vous avec
jean claude carrière adapter ce
mécanisme du roman épistolaire
on sait seulement de ce personnage
qu'ils ont l'ouïe dire aux autres
personnages mais dont l'un était en
dehors de l'être c'est pas là alors on a
essayé de délits mais qu'est ce qui se
passait vraiment avant que le verre
était écrit j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
devant mais je ne réussis alors milos
forman a fait un film dédié à manille
mais ce sont surtout les femmes qui ont
la parole
la force et le pouvoir c'est un côté le
film est superbe
très vite encore les résultats mais pas
encore les rapports du trc quinté plus
de vincennes je reçois à l'instant à
l'arrivée donc dans l'ordre le 15
le 19 le 2 le 11 et le dise voilà tout
de suite après la pub laurent cabrol va
vous parler du temps de demain vers
23h30 henri sannier vous présentera la
dernière édition de ce journal très
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain
matin